le roman ça va ça va pas apparemment
qu'est ce qui t'arrive
j'ai regardé les commentaires youtube là
tu sais bien qu'il faut jamais faire ça
ça parlait de quoi il parlait de moi
[Musique]
vous avez été un certain nombre à me
faire remarquer que je perdais mes
cheveux juste là sur le dessus bon alors
je vous en veux pas parce que déjà je
vous aime bien et puis en plus je vis ça
très bien
et quand même je voudrais vous dire deux
trois trucs à ce sujet d'abord oui je
perds mes cheveux mais vous savez quoi
eh ben c'est une maladie je vais vous
expliquer tout ça après ensuite bon
voulait sûrement pas dit méchamment et
encore une fois je vis tout ça très bien
en vrai les réflexions sur le physique
des gens bas ça peut vraiment faire mal
mais ça aussi on va reparler après alors
restez bien jusqu'à la fin donc oui j'ai
perdu mes cheveux
enfin j'ai perdu des cheveux en fait et
vous l'avez remarqué aussi j'ai même
perdu un bout de barbe juste là vous
avez vu ça a repoussé mais sahar tous
ces blancs ces caractéristiques d'une
maladie qu'on appelle la pelade là pour
la sa
[Musique]
donc voilà j'ai une pelade butin à la
pelade mais calmez vous c'est pas
contagieux
bah oui quand on sait pas en plus de
blesser les gens barriques de
s'inquiéter pour rien ça n'est pas
causée par un virus ça n'est pas une
maladie infectieuse c'est une maladie
inflammatoire auto immunes
c'est à dire que votre propre système
immunitaire pas le mien en l'occurrence
s'attaque à votre corps le mien du coup
pas le vôtre bref en tout cas ils
s'attaquent pas à celui des autres donc
pas de danger
les coupables ce sont des cellules de
notre système immunitaire qu'on appelle
des lymphocytes et qui sont une forme de
nos globules blancs
d'ordinaire ils sont plutôt cool hein
parce qu'ils nous défendre contre les
infections par exemple sauf que là ils
deviennent dingues et ils s'attaquent à
nous follicules pileux
c'est à dire là où se trouve la racine
des cheveux ou des poils attention ils
les détruisent part il est inactive
c'est une maladie qui touche les hommes
les femmes et les enfants c'est assez
fréquent d'en trouver plusieurs cas dans
la même famille et vous entendrez sans
doute dire qu'elle se déclenche souvent
après un gros stress ou un traumatisme
psychologique ya plein de témoignages de
patients qui vont dans ce sens il ya
même beaucoup de médecins qui reprennent
ça alors contre la vérité c'est que la
maladie elle est encore mal connue et
qu'aucune étude scientifique n'a
vraiment réussi à établir un lien
évident entre la pelade
[Musique]
donc je disais aucune étude scientifique
n'a réussi à établir un lien entre la
pelade et des causes psychologiques
c'est à dire qu'il en a pas ça veut dire
que ça n'a pas été prouvé
scientifiquement
bon mais comment on sait qu'on a une
pelade et qu'on n'est pas juste en train
de devenir chauve comme son père il ya
plusieurs formes de pelade mais
généralement la chute des cheveux ou des
poils est très brutal parfois juste en
quelques jours
ensuite la zone de pelade est bien
délimité souvent rondes ou ovales
même si dans certaines formes on perd
tous ses cheveux voir tous ces poils
même cécile et ses sources il peut aussi
y avoir d'autres zones touchées comme la
barbe dans mon cas mais aussi les ongles
et oui est ce que vous saviez que les
ongles c'est de la même famille que les
poêles ou les cheveux on appelle cela
des phanères vous saviez sont un peu
seul
il ya quelques années un rugbyman
professionnel s'était fait pas mal
chambré pour ses coupes de cheveux un
peu bizarre jusqu'à ce que benjamin
lapeyre c'est son nombre en a pas deux
explique ce qui lui arrivait j'ai
développé une maladie qui s'appelle la
pelade voilà donc là les gens plus ou
moins arrêtés de chambrer mais le
problème de ce bras de benjamin c'est
que la pelade ça soigne mais ça soigne
avec des médicaments qui sont interdits
pour les sportifs de haut niveau ça
soigne notamment grâce à des traitement
par corticoïdes qui sont des anti
inflammatoires
vu que ces maladies inflammatoires ça se
tient quantico ide en pommade en
injection dans le cuir chevelu ou en
comprimés la bonne nouvelle donc c'est
que ça se soigne et que ça peut même
guérir spontanément mais la mauvaise
nouvelle c'est que ça a tendance à
récidiver mais ça se rejoignent mais ça
pour finir sachez qu'en plus des
rugbymen c'est une maladie qui peut
toucher d'autres animaux mais c'est pas
les mêmes mécanismes qui entrent en jeu
donc
ne comparons pas les pas des bleus
voilà benjamin lapeyre et moi on a
choisi la même solution pour pas
complexés à cause de notre chute de
cheveux en parler expliqué du coup je me
suis dit que peut-être de temps en temps
je pourrai faire venir un invité dans
dtc qui viendra nous parler de sa
maladie son handicap
sa particularité physique des trucs qui
font qu'on se sent différent pour qu'il
nous explique comment il a appris à
vivre avec
c'est une bonne façon d'apprendre des
choses tous ensemble ethniques et les
complexes en même temps vous savez quoi
eh ben on va le faire c'est vrai donc on
se retrouve très bientôt pour de
nouvelles vidéos d'ici là aimez vous
aimez les autres prenez soin de vous et
prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
bien
[Applaudissements]